Is this the latest pawn in a global power
game?
Spy novelist and blogger Yang Hengjun was
a Chinese diplomat before he became an Australian
citizen.
He flew from the New York to Guangzhou last
week, where he mysteriously dropped off the
grid.
Friends raised the alarm when he couldn't
be contacted.
Beijing at first denied all knowledge of his
whereabouts.
But now officials have confirmed Yang is in
residential detention in Beijing and has been
charged with espionage.
Australia is demanding consular access at
the earliest opportunity.
It's also seeking urgent clarification as
to whether Yang's detention, is linked to
Canada's arrest of top Huawei executive Meng
Wanzhou in December.
China has detained several foreigners since
then, widely seen as retaliation.
Australian Foreign Minister Marise Payne sees
no evidence of a connection, for the moment.
I would be concerned if there was an indication
of that.
So we are calling on the Chinese authorities
to ensure that this matter is dealt with transparently
and fairly.
Feng Chongyi, a friend and colleague of Yang's,
says the arrest is clearly linked to what
he calls, Beijing's "hostage diplomacy".
Because of the Huawei case, I believe they
are using these people as hostages to exercise
pressure on Canadian government, on the government
of the United States and the government of
Australia as well to release Meng Wanzhou
back to China.
China's recent detention of foreign nationals
is straining its international relations.
But Beijing appears determined to play hard
ball, in a high-stakes dispute with the West.